justice maintenant patrick dils est en
prison depuis 14 ans mais il clame son
innocence et demandent la révision de
son procès de nouveaux éléments très
troublants sont apparus ces derniers
mois le tueur en série francis heaulme
se trouvait en effet sur les lieux du
drame où deux enfants avait été
assassiné à coups de pierres près de
metz en 1986 aujourd'hui la cour de
cassation a demandé un supplément
d'instruction reportages et réactions
avec estelle mathieu et yves quemener
cet après midi le lieu était bien garnie
comme si tout ce qui allait se passer
devait être exceptionnelle tout à
l'heure en montant les marches du palais
de justice la famille ses avocats savez
bien que la journée d'aujourd'hui ne
serait pas une journée ordinaire à 14
heures les cinq magistrats de la cour de
cassation devait statuer sur le sort de
leur fils ce fils de 30 ans condamné à
la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité en
1989 pour un double homicide commis en
1986 près de metz ce fils de 30 ans qui
demandent la révision de son procès à la
lueur d'un élément nouveau il est 14
heures hors caméra la chambre criminelle
rend son arrêt la procédure est
rarissime elle ordonne un supplément
d'instruction et patrick dils ne sort
pas soit ils pas remis en liberté
sortie
prévue la cour de révision est vérifiée
1986 on ose espérer qu'elle attendra pas
2014 pour vérifier le problème
car au delà de l'élément nouveau c'est à
dire la présence de francis heaulme sur
les lieux du crime jour des faits la
cour de cassation devoir désormais
vérifier emploi du temps de francis
heaulme ce jour-là rechercher son
compagnon de beuverie et saisir son
dossier médical doit figurer
l'explication de cette fameuse blessure
occasionnée le lendemain des faits à la
sortie de l'audience au seul nom de
francis heaulme les familles des
victimes un bon dit cela on ne demande
pas mieux vous savez c'est la vérité
pour l'opinion publique pour nous
puisque nous battre nous avons le
dossier un dossier
impeccable mais c'est pour l'opinion
publique parce que nathan la presse avec
tout ce qu'elle a raconté il va bien
falloir qu'on met les choses au point
c'est quoi tous lieux publics qu'elle
commence à gratter la tête maintenant à
se dire mais qu'est ce qui se passe à
cette société papa lui parce qu'on
arrivait à faire aujourd'hui plus
qu'hier le doute et non le doute sur la
culpabilité de patrick dils avec ces
derniers jours cette succession de
témoignages troublants autour de francis
sommes aujourd'hui la cour de cassation
s'est donné du temps demain patrice fête
ses 30 ans quoi qu'il en soit la justice
devra prendre une décision
un jour ou l'autre